what's up you little dirty Griswold huh
you little onomatopoeias you smoky
little almonds damn boy that smoked
almond and not crazy in that crazy that
that happened to an almond he was living
his life and maybe he hadn't you know
you know done right by his wife or he
hadn't really taken care of his family a
hundred percent but to smoke him you
know to take him out back behind in an
alley and put a damn gun to his little
to his little pointy little head just
makes you wonder what's going on man you
know but I'm here I'm here you're here
we got this you little crispy wiggers
who's ready huh let's get into something
[Music]
how could this where you turn that slow
dance into a fast things you know shake
a little bastard by the waist
[Music]
PG baby
shine that light on me right there
that's Bishop gun with shine and they
got that they got that ear hitter right
there they feel you and we feel you here
every week every week welcome to this
past weekend I hope you are doing well
you know hope you if you're doing
something I hope you got a shirt on or
don't have a shirt on you know I
remember when I was young bro
I used to love taking my [ __ ] shirt
off boy
dude I would take my shirt off all the
time bro and sometimes at inopportune
times are wrong they call them wrong
times you know I'd be at school and the
lady give me a little second serving at
him mashed potatoes and I take my damn
shirt off bro
it was almost like a way that I showed
my gratitude to things you know I
remember they had a guy he said drive
down the street over there on McGhee
Street in our neighborhood and he was a
rich man this man was really rich and he
had like a nice car like a I don't know
what it was maybe like a Buick satellite
or something I mean the thing had damn
it looked fancy brought he had a couple
probably stars and a damn half a galaxy
in the trunk of it he just was in
wealthy well-off they called it
well-to-do they said and he would drive
down the street and he was a
veterinarian and he would throw uh he
threw a lot of animal carcasses and
stuff out of a vehicle because he knew
you know he likes they would be in our
ditch and stuff and I think he just
something inside of him I think he felt
like he was giving back to the you know
to the lower class or he was doing
something or maybe he just you know like
throwing you know you know animal
carcasses out of the damn out of a nice
vehicle I don't know but uh what was I
telling you about damn dude but yeah
sometimes when I'd be out there and I'd
see half of a you know half of a rooster
hit the ditch you know or I'd see you
know maybe four fifths of a lamb or
something hit
the ditch you know a lamb body and I
would take my damn shirt Oh bro show
some respect
you know there was just something about
when you didn't have anything really to
show people sometimes you just show me a
bare skin you just show him your young
chest and your belly button you do
something you think well damn I was some
level of gratitude or in class sometime
the teacher would teach us something
real good you know I remember one time
they said lightning
they said lightning uh was made up of
the same stuff that a rainbow was and
and I it was hard for me to understand
and then and then the teacher said that
light that lightning was just a angry
rainbow and I [ __ ] dude I stood up on
my desk and took my damn shirt off bruh
you know and I damn saluted that [ __ ]
that fact that that teacher was filling
me with the facts because I need him
sometimes and there was a way we're just
kind of disrobe and yourself are showing
your chest you young chest to a as a
thank you when you didn't have anything
else to give somebody a card or a you
know a little couple of money so
something you know nothing like that but
it's coming up it's the end of September
I'm going to Maui tomorrow I'm going to
Maui so if you think about me you better
think about me and Maui guess who's
going to Maui Wow me you see what I did
there
Maui and Maui is a place off of the
coast of America in Hawaii and it's
really do you see people out there they
got they'll do all it's very Polynesian
in Polynesian some people think that
means if somebody's Polynesian it means
they you know their arms are on the
wrong sockets or whatever you know but
it's nothing to like that it means kind
of like say if you know like a flight
like a flight of I kind of Asian
people lay it like a say if a Chinese
flight crashed into a um like a like a
pineapple stand and everybody lived and
started a community that's Polynesian
right there and so I'm gonna go over
there and I'm gonna spend some time just
get to the beach relax you know let my
skin just you know my skin has been so
tight on my muscles that I just wanted
to just kind of let go a little bit
sometimes it almost feels like mas my
muscles in my skin or just doing sex all
day cuz they've just so grid it up but
I'm happy to relax there at the beach
and get a little sunshine going to a
yoga retreat place so we'll see dude you
know me brah
I might [ __ ] bail out of that bastard
in 30 minutes but I'm hoping for the
best I'm hoping to go over there and
have a good time I got to tell you I got
a couple dates coming up Bethlehem PA on
ten four and ten eight and Cleveland and
October ninth Indianapolis October 10th
Grand Rapids the 11th Detroit the 12th
Milwaukee and the 13th Madison Wisconsin
of the Maryland the oxen Hill dates have
been are going to be rescheduled I'm not
sure win yet and sayers veal New Jersey
will be rescheduled I'm not sure when
yet so that's what's going on they met
those are the reschedules the other
reschedules may not be till next year
but that's what's up man I remember
going to the beach when I was young my
mother would uh and my mother liked to
wear a bikini sometimes she would open
the windows and sit over there about a
window and have a little beer and do a
bikini and you know when I was kind of a
mama's boy and I didn't have a you know
I could even wear a bikini or anything
like that because I was a male you know
uh you know a male that was you know
more interested in you know in chicks
and stuff and so but I remember one time
I made me a little yarn
took a yarn and two bottle caps and made
me a little bikini you know and kind of
had you know had my sister tie it in the
back and just wore that little bastard
you know because I just you know my
mother was around I think I just wanted
to be like her you know I wanted to be
like my dad but he wasn't around and
also he was you know 70 80 years old so
if I was being like my dad I was just
taking naps or looking for something
that I was never gonna find or what else
was I doing if I was being like him I
used to go sleep at the park sometime my
dad liked to do that sleep at the Burger
King um you know just enjoying life
really having a law something on my dad
would make me sneak in there and get him
a little tablespoon of mayonnaise and he
would eat it off just dip his finger in
it and eat it and watch an episode of a
Three's Company or one of those
detective program he liked a lot of that
he was old-fashioned like that but my
mother used to take us to the beach we
would go the first beach I went to
Biloxi Beach and the place that the
beach is really the water was always
illegal you couldn't get in the water
they had signs up and said you know the
tests came in and this water is you know
pregnant or whatever I mean that water
was you see out there for an hour some
of the fish will come out on two or
three legs and go get a job it was that
kind of they called it illegal water I
guess or something it was just you know
they'd have the water would look at head
and look like oil it looked like an oil
spill and they put some sand around it
that's how the water was and it also had
this foam this kind of like though it
likes like the water had been brushing
its teeth and it just had a bunch of
kind of like toothpaste on the side of
it but we get out there and make little
shapes and stuff and we you could still
do a draw in the sand and you get
sunburned bad too but and they had fish
and some of the fish like they had been
through some tough [ __ ]
like some of the fifths look like they
were in like ms-13 or you know you see a
little fish swim by with like a bandana
on you know and it's like Oh pescado
hauls you feel me
pescado like woohoo bro relax ACO man
cuz it was just you know they had so
much chemicals there in Biloxi so we you
know when you went there to the beach
you couldn't you could get in the water
but you couldn't stay that long because
it would feel like your skin would burn
or look like something's kind of trying
to sneak into your body through your
elbows or through your bellybutton and
mom used to even make us put something
over our belly button or put a piece of
gum if we had a big gum we'd put that in
our belly button so that the you know if
the water was real bad or illegal or
something didn't really taint you up or
you know get into your body but but
that's not going to be the case in Maui
it's gonna be a little bit different
over there and and so I'm excited about
that what else is going on Oh Oh Chris
D'Elia
you saw this he did a thing on Instagram
where he was talking a smack okay
and I got something for you Chris D'Elia
I got there you go daddy I got that
little clap back for daddy okay I got
that little clap back for daddy and so I
want to talk about that I want to talk
about we got a lot of some good
questions that came in people talking
about the Bill burr episode we had that
gentleman inside you know the ginger to
remember you feel me and he was in here
like the other day and um and what else
we got a lot of good a lot of good calls
that came in we're gonna get to a few of
those yes so I want to get into I want
to talk to I want to respond to that
Chris D'Elia you know him and he's
really like God dude if you've ever I
mean if you've ever had something just
if you ever had your shadow someone
you'll see if you're standing outside
and you look next to yourself there's
something real dark right there and
that's not a you know this isn't a
racial thing or anything it's your
shadow and if you ever seen your shadow
sometime
if you look over real fast you'll see it
you know doing something they're doing
something naughty
you know maybe looking at a nudie
magazine or you know doing one of them
um clove cigarette you know we're doing
something real nasty or something were
touching his little dark little wiener
and that's Chris D'Elia right there you
know he lives on the north side of a
tree you know what I'm saying he's that
he's that uh he's that he's the dark art
and he's a dark art man and he came at
me brother he came at me and and I want
to talk about that right here I want to
play here's a clip of what he said right
here I also want to talk about this one
more thing before we go so Theo my buddy
my arch-nemesis on this podcast thing
made fun of me for canceling a show
because of cuz you did because I
couldn't get there literally couldn't
get this yeah you know what actually let
me say this man I will never cancel the
show cool here's what things oh that's a
great sound bite that's a great sound
but see what he's doing here I have some
news for you
Theo didn't cancel the show Theo
canceled his whole European tour oh me
too before it happened because he got a
movie so not only did he do what he said
he would never do how he's doing the
same thing I'm doing I would never do
that what he's doing who's this stepdad
now and who's the real daddy did he was
what was he okay okay that's enough
first of all Chris D'Elia wears
deodorant on his whole arm okay
so people should know that that he
starts at the wrists with the stick and
brings it all the way up to the pit so
that right there that's something you
know I want to say this has crystal you
ever eaten a egg sandwich that he cooked
the egg on the top of a hot Ford has he
uh no have I yes as Chris D'Elia ever
battled rare diseases and beat him or
tied them even oh no but have I done it
yeah
has Chris D'Elia ever fought a guy in a
sharp dragon suit outside of a JC
Penney's when he was younger and beat
the guy you know to you know to to two
to one rounds uh
no but have I done it oh yes is
crystally a gated community gangster uh
yes he is has he ever lived next door to
an adult video store that also sold
shrimp okay and still managed his
emotions well even though sometimes he
was you know you know pleasuring himself
but also you know there's horseradish in
the area you feel me
okay oh no have I yes would I ever
cancel a show because of weather
no would yes you will not find me
postponed in a show because of the air
elements okay storm rain fire second
coming third coming the case Jesus gets
lost you feel me sunlight no light
drizzle missiles drizzles ice missiles I
will be there bring it on mother nature
and will crystal you be there no will I
be there yes
so I'm the real daddy all right if you
put my Johnson on a record player and
played it backwards you can hear it go
Danny Danny Danny cuz I got that Bose
surround pound you feel me what's that I
hear someone coming up the steps yeah
it's the step daddy cause a little bit
and the real daddy is the one that
brings home the metal bacon baby you
feel mad
Nettie's home just so everybody knows
what's going on around here all right
let's get into some Q&A let's start
right here from patreon
David Laval sent this in great
conversation with Bill burr and it was
cool to see him giving you some feedback
and advice from a guy who's been on top
of the game for a long time was there
anything in particular he said that
resonated with you or made you think
differently about comedy and your career
thank you David a little avail la balle
um you know it was it was it was tough -
it was tough it was tough I was really
really glad that bill came in he and I
had never had a long conversation in
person before ever we had a couple of
conversations on the phone and so I
think it was kind of a new you know I
don't know if we knew each other's vibes
that well I mean Ronald the key knew
mine very well and that makes sense you
know I mean I'm an oyster you know I'm a
barnacle and he's a cruise ship you know
and it was tough and it was it was tough
like I couldn't it was just a tough
conversation man it just wasn't I wasn't
bad you know what it was in hindsight it
was exactly what I should have expected
you know he's Bill burr he's the reason
there's a reason that that I think he's
the best because he's just you know he
is just he's a train man he's just a
train and he has his thoughts and he has
his his ideas and his and he's poignant
about him and I don't know if I had
expectations in my head that it was
going to be more of like a
jovial chatter or I just think our you
know I just think our ideas of of
conversation or the way we we conversate
are just different a little bit and and
he is exactly what I you know he's
really he was but he was bill burr to a
tee he's brash he's he's he's pulling in
he's exactly
he's exact you know he's he's really he
really is like a like a NASA you know
like a rocket you know when I'm more
like sometimes like feel Armstrong you
know you find me to kind of moseying
around on the moon you know monitor and
how I feel and he's more he's that
master-blaster he'll shoot right by you
and so yeah there were some things he
said that really did kind of resonate
with me I think when he said that you
have to work well with others you know
he kind of said you got to get over not
working with others um and I think some
of that it's true it's like I got to
look at myself and it's like well if I'm
gonna be work in certain circles then I
have to be sure that I'm comfortable
with it but I got a I kind of have to
make a decision so I'm not waffling all
the time because half my choices you
could put syrup on him [ __ ] they
waffles you know I'm here I'm there I
got butter I got you know modren so who
knows so that was pretty good um what
else did I take away from it I
definitely I came away feeling like like
it was probably good like if I had some
ego that maybe this was letting some air
out of it you know I felt sometimes like
I couldn't like I didn't know what to
say and I don't know if that's the best
place to be sometimes you're supposed to
be interviewing somebody or having a
conversation with them
but I'm not like you know I wasn't
disappointed in myself or anything like
that I just I think we're two different
types of people you know when we talked
about material and stuff and I said well
I treasure my material more and for me
that's because I do stories I tell
stories you know and so for me those
things are personal and they're more you
know there's more of a personal value to
them in that sense but I think overall I
think no matter what you know I was
grateful to be able to have him come in
he's who we thought he was and we let
him off the hook that's what I feel like
you know he's exactly you know he was
bill burr to a tea to a tea and he was
exactly who the thing that I loved about
him on stage is exactly what I loved
about exactly what he was in person and
so you know I think I think some of this
stuff about Manning up and sacking up
and I think that's right I think I
needed to hear that it doesn't mean that
I can't still be myself for that but
it's nice to sometimes just you know
sometimes you want to hear people need
to hear you sometimes only certain ways
you can hear something
you know sometimes somebody will beat
you with a damn bat but if you don't
care who's beating you you won't you
only pay attention you'll just have bat
marks all over your back and legs inside
and you know an F elsewhere but butts
and every now and then somebody who you
know who holds some weight in your life
will hit you with that bat with a bat
full of facts bra that fact bat and get
you [ __ ] together
you need a man up so I think it was
sometimes tough to like kind of joke
around or what our what our vibes were I
think we're just kind of off you know
again I'm more like that feel Armstrong
and he's more like a little bit more
like Rocket Man but I'm grateful that
I'm grateful that he came in and and
that's really I guess let me think is
there anything else anything
particularly resonated with your main
thing differently about comedy and your
career
you know I think it made me think that
if I'm gonna get involved with Hollywood
and that sort of stuff that I need to
kind of come to some peace with it you
know I think somewhere inside of me
sometimes I have a lot of just trust
issues overall in every space of my life
and commitment issues and every in every
aspect you know I don't want to be
exploited I don't want someone to take
advantage of me
so it's a lot of fear [ __ ] so you know I
don't think there are any any accidents
I think everything happens for a reason
and and so yeah it's like what can I
take away from that experience so I
think that's most of my thoughts on it
you know sometimes always how to kind of
spoken up a little bit more but I think
I just didn't really know kind of what
to expect or whatever and so once things
kind of got just going in this just
direction I was like I felt like I was
on a um you ever when you're learning to
ride a bike and you start the first time
it starts going and you're like you're
like I can't get it I can't get it and
then it's going you're like woohoo and
then you just crash right into the side
of uh Colgate toothpaste blue Chevelle
you know and this [ __ ] gets out and
starts talking [ __ ] doing it's not even
hers she's just sitting in it smoking so
it was kind of like that you know I just
things got going downhill or going you
know down bill and I couldn't you know I
just was on for the ride at a certain
point and um so yeah I think it was in
some ways it was learning experience and
I don't even know what I learned from it
sometimes but I'm sure that certain
things will pop up and I was just you
know I'm glad that I got to sit down
with somebody that I really really I
mean he's just so fearless you know he's
just so fearless and I wish I would have
asked him more about like parenting a
little bit uh you know about things you
know what things that he loves about his
wife I don't know I was kind of thinking
about stuff like that
I could have asked him you know
you know more about like his material
and what does it mean when he gives it
away and that sort of thing but we're
also at different points in our career
so him you know you know the world that
he's living in is different than the one
that I'm living in but but yeah you know
I think I just take from it what I can
and and I you know and in the end just
be glad that he came and sat down with
me you know I could let it kind of hurt
my ego a little and and I don't think it
did that but I think if there was some
ego in me that needed to be corrected
then you know humility is always even
though it's painful sometimes it's a
it's a rabbit that I'll let you know run
around in my shirt so I'll get that a
little fricking bunny
that'll bust my bust my ego up and put
it in my shirt sometimes and let that
[ __ ] hop around bro and just show my
chest to it you know how I'm doing it so
my bookie at the end of a hard week it's
great to sit down and take some time off
and watch some football and lay some of
your hard-earned wages on those that on
those you know those animals on the
field and and it is nice from football's
back even if you like three dollars six
dollars nine dollars on your own you
know on whoever on Yale to beat your
mother-in-law you know where Beach you
know or beat somebody you don't like but
um but I got to tell you guys that if
you bet you got a bet with my bookie I
wouldn't be telling you guys to bet with
them unless they were the best if you
like to bet you know if you don't like
to bet then you don't like to bet but if
you're the kind of guy that likes to bet
a little and win a lot try a parlay
that's where you take two shots at it
you do two shots and if you get them
both and you you you kill that big that
lamb that Falcon if all your picks come
through you'll multiply your winnings
that's what I mean
join now and my bookie will double your
first deposit
that's right use promo code th EO to
activate the offer that's promo code th
EO to activate the offer visit my bookie
AG today that's right go to my bookie
dot AG today and and you play and you
win and you get paid
also look I came home the other day and
they got that box of meat out front and
dude it's so funny because I was hungry
I didn't have any meat on me I don't
have a knife I wasn't near a zoo so I
probably wasn't gonna have a lot of good
meat but Bam Bam Bam what is it it's
meat
not everyone has convenient to access
high quality meat you know usually you
have to be on the throat you know on the
on the Sahara or you got to be a you
know near a petting zoo or something
that night but now you can get a hundred
percent grass-fed beef you can get
free-range organic chicken I mean these
chickens have been all over you know
I'll probably see some in Maui this
weekend you can get heritage breed pork
God dang can you imagine that having you
a couple of little uh little sausages
and tastes in its history or wild-caught
salmon they catch up with the damn
handout there you see one boy with a big
hand out there catch them and they bring
it right to you in the box that's
butcher box butcher box believes that
everyone deserves high-quality humanely
sourced meat you want that meat ladies
huh it's so easy to have butcher box
meat sent to you and it doesn't spoil
your mindset out there for 24 hours
every month butcher box ships a curated
selection of high quality meat right to
my home all meat is free of antibiotics
and added hormones it's packed fresh and
shipped frozen and vacuum sealed you can
hear the Dyson they used right before
they sent that thing to you right now
butcher box is offering new members
ground beef for life gb 4 l you feel me
get that 10 that's 2 pounds of ground
beef in every box for the life of their
subscription plus $20 off their first
box that's right just go to butcher box
comm slash Theo or enter promo code Theo
at checkout
that's butcher box.com slash Theo or
InterPro mo code Theo at checkout 2
pounds of ground beef in every box for
the life of your subscription plus $20
off that first package Wow
butcher box alright let's take a call
right here the hotline is always 9 8 5 6
6 4
5:03 hey CEO is Zach Johnson from
Evangel University in Springfield
Missouri and I just wanted to ask you
what's your biggest fear hey my biggest
fear
Thank You Zach for calling them from
Evangel over there my biggest fear its
commitment man I think or if you're
talking land animal then I'm saying
probably coyote I think tiger but less
likely to see a tiger because I'm in
that you know I live in United States in
North America so I'd say coyote coyote
or Mountain Cat Man a mountain cat
scares me did I think about going for a
jog sometimes then I think about a
mountain cat and I just I'm just stay at
home sometimes and just relax or
something I have some you know get some
make a popcorn or do something relaxing
but otherwise commitment you know I find
I struggle with commitment and almost
every every space in my life and it's
something I do you know that I need to
spend some time on and I'm not being
hard on myself I just want to be I want
to be the best of myself and so I want
to figure out why I have such a tough
time with it you know and it's also some
of it is a meat generation you know we
live in a time where everybody can you
can kind of have everything you can have
everything you can you can do you know
you can you can be alone and you know
everything is individualized more and so
I think that that doesn't help us
realize and how much we really need each
other
but for me it's commitment across work
across relationships and even being
staying committed to myself you know
saying I'm going to do something and
following through with it and that's
where you built integrity really is by
staying you know saying yourself okay
this is how I'm gonna behave and then
behave in that way and I don't really do
the best job of that you know I try
though but uh but I think that I can try
more effectively and I think I can
tribal it by maybe getting some help
to try not alone that makes sense let's
take another call that came in right
here here we go hey oh this is Jason
from Central Florida
what's up Jason thank you for hitting it
up baby Central Florida and that's not
there a lot of reptilian over there
I mean you [ __ ] do you take a walk
through the swamp and come in come just
you walk right out of the water come you
have some damn snakeskin leggings on
you know you'll finally chup in your
grandmother's brassiere of a tear know
things will suck on your tit right there
beautiful big animals over there a lot
of big mollusk a lot of sunburnt it is
over there as well excuse me I shouldn't
say that mana I don't want to be
thinking about that right now let's do
it
I just bought tickets for me and my
future father-in-law for your show on
Bethlehem PA and I'm pumped man can't
wait to come up there and see it just
got the plane tickets confirmed I don't
know what my father-in-law is going to
think about [ __ ] it he's going he's from
Bethlehem so I thought this would be an
awesome opportunity for me and him to
you know Mickey connection there in see
you gang man thank you you bringing out
that father-in-law and coming in
Bethlehem that's like Joseph and Jesus
right there it really is that you know
that uh that connection and Joseph was
the step daddy people don't realize you
know they should really mark that out in
the Bible they should even mark it out
and just stepdaddy's day on the calendar
because everybody has so many
stepdaddy's now it's it's a shame
there's not an opportunity you know a
comfortable opportunity to buy him a
cookie or a sweet you know buy a mom you
know a little bit you know what sugary
delectable or something like that and do
something nice for them because they're
good to you sometimes or they brought
your mother some cheap jewelry or
something or got her a boat but thank
you guys for coming look taking us a
loved one if you don't have a connection
with your you know somebody you love at
their parent a good way to make a
connection is to take them to a comedy
show because they'll see what you think
is humorous
and it can really bridge a lot of the
gap right there let's take a call again
the hotline ninety five six six four
nine five zero three and also I got to
say that on that if you smell something
in you a few gotcha
if you put your nose down down near my
body you know and you smell something
it's pumpkin spice well it could be
these new me undies because it's that
time of year you know the leaves are
crunchy the breeze is crisp and it's
onesie season it's officially fall yup
if you put your ear up outside to the
window you could hear a scarecrow in the
distance you know smoking a pipe or
looking to buy a gram off somebody and
me undies the softest undies in the
world knows a thing or two about the
fall because when it's fall time the
weather gets you know a little naughty
and the weather really it'll just kind
of sneak up on your balls and snicker at
them with a cold little giggle and the
thing you can do there is if you if you
the thing you can do then is you can get
a onesie from me undies imagine roll it
out in front of your girl with that sexy
ass onesie you know I'm saying in one
zipper you could show your chest and get
you junk out and urinate as well if you
want and I mean they're soft they're
softer than the foam on the top of that
pumpkin spice latte you feel me they're
softer than your favorite hoodie me
undies they're designed to be the
softest thing you ever put on your body
they're available in sizes extra small
in case you got a little bitty friend
that likes to get naked or unmake 'add 2
to 4 XL and we have a great offer for
our listeners support the podcast guys
for any first-time purchasers you get
15% off and free shipping
yup 15% off and free shipping me undies
dot-com slash weekend that's me undies
dot-com slash weekend and and I've got
them on right now a my god I mean it
feels like just like a like a soft
little you know that that downy snuggle
bear' it feels like he's just playing
with my nuts and I asked right now
that's how soft these things are on your
body
it feels like that little downy snuggle
bear' is just kind of rubbing his neck
up against the back of my nuts right now
and if you don't think that's soft that
my goodness you don't know what things
are so go support the podcast if you can
me undies comm slash weekend let's take
another call that came in right here
hey do man huge fan this is a great
Raymond James that's my music name I
make music Raymond James a music maker
and that's also the name of the stadium
in Tampa Bay Raymond James Stadium Ray J
is also a man I think he was a famous
rapper something and he stole
everybody's money off that Fire Island
let's hear more but anyways I was I was
really excited to see that you're
throwing Milwaukee in October is is back
foot back up
that's just great news man and I don't
know if I'm calling a little bit late
about this but I have a momma I'd
actually like to nominate four single
single nights moms and hate hours that
mama nation that mama nation we got you
baby
homeward named destiny Gonzalez she's 27
she's she's got two adorable little kids
I'm only 23 but I I met her in Nonna my
whole life and unfortunately the guy is
you know he was he wasn't in the kids
lives at all but she's a she's a great
mom and I just come to the show either
way just wanted to let you know gang
brother and I didn't mean to cut you off
but I'm gonna have Nick reach out to you
and we will we'll line it up we'll do
something special for her so thank you
for the nomination there Milwaukee yeah
we good we haven't gonna do that in a
while so thank you and I'm excited to
come back to these some of these places
you know we took them off the books and
putting them back on the books and and
I'm excited I've been working on some
new material a little bit the past
couple weeks this is still going to be
the the dark art store I only have about
20 shows left on it
so it's like about 8 or 10 shows here in
the US and then 10 shows over there in
Europe and that'll be the end of it that
crazy man it would be the end of it man
it's a it kind of a little bit but it's
not sad yet it's still exciting let's
take a call that came in right here here
we go come on Gio's Michael calling from
Baltimore
I got a issue here I've been with my
girl for for 2 years and we had a little
conversation yesterday where we're kind
of came out that she doesn't really want
to have sex anymore oh okay so she took
that nookie huh she took that nookie off
the Mesa baby off the table she took
that nookie off the Mesa
so I'm guessing titties only or what is
it let's hear more very even with me she
just doesn't enjoy sex at all and she
she thinks back to the times and she was
single and she was out there and you
know she had a couple little Rob's
herself and she said she's never really
getting dick that's what they say are
getting you know doing sick sorry I
shouldn't said that part about the dick
but uh yeah man well it seemed like
she's been out there before she
obviously knows what it's like to have
sex and you guys have had sex it seems
like so sorry I'm just making sure I
know all the clues to this let's go more
I guess back then she said you know in
the excitement of going out and meeting
new people but not really even the
sexual aspect thing we're gonna have to
make a decision here next mage you gonna
graduate from grad school and go and get
a job somewhere in the country and and
you know I'm either gonna follow her and
be with her I'm gonna stay where I'm at
I don't know what to do
well I think I appreciate your calling
man you know if she doesn't want to have
sex and you might have to move with
there it's really up to you it's like do
you is sex important to you you know you
could always just draw a picture of her
in the bathroom or in the shower or
something and masturbate to it and live
together
you could let's hear if any more clues
onward I don't know if I can be with
somebody who doesn't want to have sex
yeah I think it's risky man it's risky
and it also seems she could be a lesbian
and a lesbian somebody that I have sex
usually at first they have sex behind
your back with other women and then they
just go have sex with women or it's not
even sex I mean it is sex but it's
different you know there's not a wiener
so it sounds like you got a friend you
know and I hate to say that to you I
know you love her but it sounds like you
have a like a loving friend so what I
would do is I would talk to her and see
if there's any chance for you guys to
have children because maybe she just
wants to have kids and you guys do you
know are just loving parents and you get
your sexual elsewhere you know you get
your sex down the block down there buddy
Casey's general store some meet a bad
[ __ ] over there by the Hot Cheetos or
something or by the little law sometime
their pizzas in there on a little
wheelie on that you know kind of cooking
wheelie but it sounds like you have a
friend to me so my suggestion would be
just to communicate with her real
clearly because if you go spending gas
money and going across America or
something on that you might end up in
one of those named Colts or whatever so
but I wish you well man and I appreciate
you calling in let's take another call
here here we go I feel sure Asian
brother Justin from Jersey what's up J
from jurors how y'all doing out there
Jersey dude and I saw a friend of mine
brought somebody um when he was real
real young dude somebody stabbed him in
in New Jersey home word calling man to
see how you been I've been doing pretty
good man thanks for asking um what's
been going on not much I'm supposed to
go to a party tonight actually David
Spade invited me out so you know I'm
name-dropping and he's coming on the
podcast this week
oh but what else oh not much man I
haven't been feeling that good but I'm
trying to just find some more motivation
I'm trying to just you know honestly
quit looking for motivation outside of
myself and look for it more inside of
myself because that's what's missing for
me right now you know I'm not [ __ ]
you know I'm not just kind of sacking up
and just saying look this is what I want
and this is you know and it's okay and
it's okay to you know to to progress and
move forward and and stuff like that but
anyway I'm rambling about me let's hear
more about you brother a concern right
now is I just started meeting this new
girl letter online we uh we had a
relations on the first date okay and
that's X it could be sex could be oral
it could be hard oral you know and a lot
of times a lady will get down I've seen
on the internet they'll get on their
knees and you get behind him and hit him
with that hummingbird you feel me and
that's either where you kind of do like
a real hard tongue reel in and out like
you're uh you know trying to taste a
battery but being afraid trying to you
know touch the top of a Duracell but
having fear you or you some people can
get an erection real quick and drop it
at the same time real back and forth
real fast and they'll just kind of do
that on the lady's body on that and do
that hummingbird over there looking for
that sweet that moisture daddy but Jesus
Christ man I'm getting hard thinking
about all this what is going on today
man I think my I think my own thing
about Hawaii brah
my body's already in Hawaii let's hear
more I really like her we bought really
well somewhere interests you know good
spooning size all that good stuff
just uh just bogging me out a little bit
but um she's a very highly sexual woman
oh yes you got that fifth gear brah you
know what I'm saying she's into somebody
just squeezing on her shoulders or on
her tits
let's go more brother and or anytime in
a lot of I know a girl used to wear real
heavy shoes when she would [ __ ] and she
put even like what she would weighed
them down so you had she just had these
heavy yes but you know the her feet were
just heaviest [ __ ] they're just real
just real you know like almost like her
own gravity at the end of each leg just
you know she had about 16 pounds of shoe
and you know sometimes metal kind of
tied at the bottom of it this sexual you
know people are wild too conservative
about her sexuality so I'm just uh want
to know your opinion man but about a
woman that you know is open to relations
on the first date well I mean you have
to be open to it too you know women are
a lot more sexual these days you know
when I was young you had to see I
remember one girl which shows sometime
would drive by and press her vagina
against a window of a Ford Mustang 5.0
and you know that was a lot I was a lot
of the most of the sex I had when I was
young was just seeing her go Bob you
know once a quarter or whatever once a
yeah three or four times a year but uh
what was this about but you have to UM
oh here's the thing brother
you had sex two on the first date so
both y'all did so anything you think
about her you got to think about you
kind of you know just you know so if you
want her if you want things to be
different with her then you got to make
it different you know take her to a
splash park or take her to uh you know
get her over there to the Dairy Queen or
to the Family Dollar you got to go do
some shopping get some craft stuff make
kites or something you know take her on
a date or two without touching and then
bring her over for a little bit of all
you know get it get some of those get a
pack of Johnson's brats and grill them
bad [ __ ] uh let her smell the smoke
it at meat and then later put a little
bit of that you know uh tenderize around
your junk and hit her with that last bra
you know that I think that's six the
brach cuz a lot of them coming a package
of five my stepdad used to make him and
he passed away but before he died he
would grill him up all the time and he
that's all he ever talked about - he had
Alzheimer's and he would talk about
Johnson then Johnsonville brats so but
yeah I mean if she has sex on the first
date in you and you like her I think you
gotta separate those two things you know
you could tell her look I really like
you I wanna you know kind of take things
a little slower or you guys can just
keep having sex and just also like her
so but it's not like both you guys
engaged in it I love you bro have a good
one man I appreciate you calling in um
all right I think yes I got to go to the
beach uh here I'll put this one call man
here we go thank you guys for calling as
as always the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three here
we go and let down there Reyes onward
there you go el army I don't I don't be
dubbed e boy big wave Dave out there bro
don't let him drown you feel me cuz you
some other people have a name like that
you know splashy Johansson or whatever
or [ __ ] uh you know they'll have you
know Lake Jake or something like that
and then they drown so cuz they're you
know they try to live up to the name all
word okay you talking about that green a
leafy desert huh
you made some weed brownies in what else
homeward now feel you look Brown feel
Armstrong you got me go
the next morning I got a call
my father he said he said your mother's
in the emergency room oh man I'm sorry
to hear that dude I just didn't expect
you to say that just now because you in
big wave Dave boy or whatever his name
was you know you guys were just having
snacks Oh word well that's something bro
that's not nothing
nothing is you know maybe sitting
sitting outside on the porch or
something or you know getting in your
car and you haven't started it yeah but
you haven't you're not looking at your
phone yet or anything you're just
sitting in there all word little bit of
those brownies he left in the morning
after last night I mean I'm sorry so
yeah just feeling a little guilty
probably won't ever tell it and yeah
it's just ahead low to decay on on these
for the rest of my life
gang gang baby gang bro yeah that's a
lot when you're out there drugging young
mother secretly through dessert that's
heavy
you know that's real real heavy and your
mother you know the lady that brought
you out of her own womb bro she sprouted
you out into the world through that
Vahine Papa and you drugging her out at
the house she can't even go to her own
icebox and get a couple of sweet treats
without you [ __ ] dousing her up hey
sis crease to Papa I mean come home a
young mother who jest aided you inside
of her body brother who sprouted you
from the size of nothing and who just L
just let you down that magic sweat
elevator into the world into existence
and you out there dousing her up with
them little Cosby cakes Brooke come on
man bro you need to write your mama a
letter dude and mail it to her and tell
her what happened bro I don't think it's
the thing you say face-to-face I think
you sent her a letter and say look mom
I'm that dude you know that drugs his
mother I'm the guy who drugs his mother
through night times you know through
sweets through you know morsels through
you know dessert because who you know
I'm saying what's next you're gonna you
know slip your father a couple things a
Molly bra you're gonna put a little
percocet in yes and your sister-in-laws
pudding where does it end
so I think coming clean breath and
that's it and they'll call you big wave
Dave and come and clean Jeanne and I
don't even even not Jean but if it was
it would make great sense there so
that's all I got man that's all I have
for you today I'm going to Hawaii
I want to thank Nick I want to thank you
guys and what else is going on not much
I'm excited to just kind of chill out
for a week and I literally just decided
kind of at the last minute I've been
hoping that to get things all lined up
and uh and everything is is okay so
thank you guys for calling in thank you
guys for the support and I'm excited to
come and hit those tour dates and I hope
you're doing well you know hope you're
making it through another week it's an
exciting time of year to look forward to
you know with Christmas coming up and
you know they got all the fancy drinks
at Starbucks coming up you know and it's
a beautiful time here it's a good time
to meet somebody new or to let somebody
know you care about them it's a good
time to make your mother some cookies
that are you know that aren't a Schedule
one narcotic so it's really just a it's
a good time to be somebody and to do
something for someone and uh yeah I'm
gonna try to just just take it easy man
and be grateful I'm grateful you guys
here today you guys be good to
yourselves because you guys deserve it
you know I know that I say it every week
but but I mean okay
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could I be so far from my
home and my mind is somewhere else but
when I found it our patch up where it's
been grown now I'm just on the breeze
and that beautiful and like these leaves
that must be
[Music]